The foreign key constraint keeps
the link between the tables
by preventing invalid data from being
inserted into the foreign key column,
because the value has to be
one of the values contained in
the table the constraint points to.
Well, what does this mean for testing?
It means that we cannot test the weather
table without having the location table,
because the foreign key constraint
enforces that the location ID is a valid
ID in the location table.
It also means that we have to use
the result of an insert in the location
table in order to insert
in the weather table.
In other words,
the weather table cannot be unit tested
independently from the location table.
We are going to be writing
a database test for sunshine,
which will have to
work with a constraint.